repos
go
votre attention s'il vous plaît ici
moscou en direct de la place rouge pour
le défilé des célébrations du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire qui mit fin
à la grande guerre patriotique 1941-1945
[Musique]
au drapeau au drapeau de la victoire et
au drapeau de la fédération de russie
[Musique]
sur la place rouge le principal symbole
de la victoire le drapeau d'assaut de la
150e division de fusiliers dit drizza
c'est ce drapeau rouge hissé sur le rail
ce tag qui a annoncé au monde entier que
le soldat soviétique était parvenue
jusqu'à berlin est avait écraser
l'ennemi juré
[Musique]
ce drapeau de la victoire est sacrée
pour chaque russe c'est la relique qui
nous a été remise en 1945 par nos pères
et nos grands pères qui ont donné leur
vie pour la paix est notre avenir
aujourd'hui le drapeau de la fédération
de russie est l'étendard de la victoire
sont fermement tenu en main par des
militaires du bataillon de la garde
d'honneur du sang 54e régiment de
commandement preobrazhensky à savoir les
sergents anton mikhailov et d'huîtres et
monast et les offres
[Musique]
repos
garde à vous saluer à gauche
[Musique]
le défilé militaire est saluée par le
général d'armée sergueï choïgou ministre
de la défense de la fédération de russie
au son de la marche interprété lors du
défilé de la victoire le 24 juin 1945 le
général phùng huu se dirige vers le
centre de la place rouge pour se faire
prendre en compte de l'état du
dispositif
c'est le général d'armée oleg yelnikov
commandant en chef des troupes
terrestres qui commande le défilé
militaire
reste que fédérateur trice cammas
qu'organisera la parade à ce n'est pas
vrai
les lecteurs inquiet sur ce dernier
passe trop mais comment de shippagan
d'une erreur hormis ces locaux
[Musique]
début du passage en revue des troupes du
défilé
[Musique]
le général sergueï choigou va saluer les
troupes terrestres
[Musique]
salut aux troupes terrestres
salutations à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
[Musique]
ces dernières années l'armée russe a
atteint un niveau supérieur de formation
elle est le garant sur de la sécurité
militaire de l'êta les militaires des
troupes terrestres sont toujours prêts à
se lever pour défendre la patrie et ses
intérêts nationaux
[Musique]
salutations à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
le ministre de la défense adresse au
détachement d'honneur des forces
aérospatiale ses félicitations à
l'occasion du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire la veille permanente assurée
par les chasseurs et les bombardiers
stratégiques un cycle par les forces de
défense antiaérienne les opérations dans
le domaine spatial et le transport est
reportée du matériel et des hommes
telles sont quelques-unes des missions
pratique rempli par les forces
aérospatiale russe
[Musique]
salutations à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
le ministre de la défense de la défense
salue les unités d'honneur des
militaires des troupes de protection
nucléaires chimiques et biologiques de
transmission et des détachements de
district militaire ouest
aujourd'hui ce sont plus de 14000 et
militaires qui participent aux défilés
[Musique]
la santé dares
salutations à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
le ministre de la défense salue les
unités d'honneur des troupes aéroportées
de transport ferroviaire des troupes de
missiles stratégiques de la garde
nationale du fsb et du ministère des
situations d'urgence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salutations à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
[Musique]
le ministre de la défense adresse ses
félicitations à l'occasion de la journée
de la victoire aux unités d'honneur de
la marine aux troupes du génie aux
femmes militaires aux unités étrangères
aux plus jeunes participants du défilé
c'est à dire les élèves des instituts
militaire souvorov nash imhoff et aux
pupilles du corps de cadets et de yuna
mia c'est à dire jeunes armés
le général sergueï choïgou a terminé de
passer les troupes en revue et va rendre
compte au président de la fédération de
russie commandant en chef des forces
armées russes vladimir poutine
[Musique]
général shogo présente à vladimir
poutine le dispositif repos
[Musique]
chers citoyens de russie
chers anciens combattants
chers invités venus de l'étranger
soldats matelots sergent adjudant
camarades officiers généraux amiraux et
félicitations à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire qui a conclu
la grande guerre patriotique
cette victoire qui a défini l'avenir de
la planète pour des dizaines d'années et
qui est resté dans l'histoire comme
l'événement le plus significatif ayant
la plus grande ampleur et qui a une
signification morale cette année les
cérémonies traditionnelles ceux des
rouges se déroule le 24 juin c'est à
dire exactement jour pour jour 75 ans
après le défilé qui avait été donnée ici
même devant les murs du kremlin
ce défilé qui était celui des vainqueurs
ce défilé est resté comme un événement
mais morale c'est-à-dire le symbole de
la victoire du bien sur le mal de la vie
sur la mort au nom de tous les
défenseurs de la patrie
les drapeaux les étendards de l'ennemi
ont été jetés ici sur la place rouge
quand en marque de mépris pour cette
horreur sur la marche rouge les
régiments les unités qui ont participé
aux combats ont défilé et tous
étaient présents ici tout ce qui n'avait
pas épargné leur vie pour défendre la
paix y est ce qui évidemment sont
revenus des millions de combattants
étaient restés sur le terrain sur les
champs de bataille et donc c'est la
mémoire aujourd'hui de tous ceux qui
n'ont pas pu être aussi et donc la
mémoire des ped et chis défi des pères
des mères des grands pères des grands
mères des époux des soeurs des frères
des camarades de régiment des proches
des amis nous portons le deuil de tous
ceux qui nous ont quittés je déclare une
minute de silence
nous garderons toujours en mémoire que
c'est le peuple soviétique a vaincu le
nazisme
des millions de personnes d'ethnie
différente de toutes les républiques de
l'union soviétique
sur le front dans les arrières dans les
sections de partisans se sont battus
pour défendre avec courage et unité leur
terre natale
ils ont poursuivi ce combat ils ont
libéré les pays occupés par les nazis
dans toute l'europe
ils ont sauvé du nazisme et de son
idéologie mortifère l'allemagne et il
est impossible d'imaginer ce que serait
devenu le monde si l'armée rouge n'était
pas venu au secours de la paix personne
n'avait le besoin de guerre de deux
victoires de de triomphe mais simplement
il voulait remporter cette victoire et
revenir chez eux ils ont payé un prix
très précieux pour cette victoire
notre devoir est de garder cela en
mémoire de nous souvenir que le peuple
soviétique à supporter le plus grand
poids et 1945
près de 80% des troupes avaient été
mobilisés dans ce combat et la cohésion
du peuple russe a permis cette victoire
et c'est cela qui a permis de combattre
complètement ce mal
total et 600 division ont détruit
75% des chars des avions et jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'au point final de cette
victoire de cette guerre juste de cette
guerre impitoyable
nous avons aujourd'hui un droit 2 est un
devoir de garder cette victoire de
préserver cet héritage pour nos enfants
nos petits enfants
aujourd'hui le défilé militaire de rend
hommage à ce devoir et aux sacrifices
accomplis par les générations qui nous
ont précédés et aujourd'hui les
militaires russes vont défiler sur la
place rouge avec des représentants des
armées de différents pays l'azerbaïdjan
la kirghizie l'ouzbékistan l'arménie la
mongolie l'inde la serbie le
turkménistan l'ouzbékistan
nous sommes heureux d'accueillir nos
amis venus de différents pays ici à
moscou à moscou pour rendre hommage à
tous ceux qui ont défendu la paix sur la
planète
nous n'oublierons pas nos alliés et le
deuxième front ouvert en europe
occidentale en juin 1944 a permis à tous
les pays qui luttait contre hitler de
remporter cette victoire sur le nazisme
dans tous les pays d'europe
nous savons nous savons que ceux qui
aujourd'hui ceux qui ont conscience de
ce défi que c'est un défi qui se pose à
l'ensemble de l'humanité
gardons le courage l'espoir d'une vie
pacifique et aujourd'hui gardons encore
les valeurs d'amitié et d'ouverture pour
un dialogue sur toutes les questions qui
sont d'actualité à l'ordre du jour
international
ce sont les préoccupations de sécurité
qui sont si importants dans le monde de
chang'an d'aujourd'hui et ce n'est
qu'ensemble que nous pouvons vaincre les
nouvelles menaces qui se posent à nos
chers amis
aujourd'hui les anciens combattants de
la grande guerre vivent dans différents
pays
mais il n'est pas possible de les
diviser
face à l'exploit qu'ils ont accompli
ensemble et cet exploit sans aucune
exagération fait partie de l'héritage de
l'entendre de l'ensemble de l'humanité
et notre reconnaissance est immense par
votre vie par votre sort vous avons
montré qu'il est important de préserver
les valeurs de la paix de l'humanisme et
nous ferons tout ce qui dépend de nous
pour honorer votre mémoire et ne jamais
abandonner ce devoir
c'est notre responsabilité devant le
présent et l'avenue gloire à la
génération de ceux qui ont vaincu le
nazisme
gloire aux héros de la grande guerre
patriotique
ouah
[Musique]
le défilé garde-à-vous en marche par
bataillons garder la distance
[Musique]
le premier bataillon marche tout droit
garder les lignes mans
c'est le début du défilé des troupes à
pied
le défilé militaire et placé sous les
ordres du général d'armée oleg salenko
va
[Musique]
sur la place rouge les jeunes musiciens
de l'école de musique militaire du
ministre russe de la défense
valeri khalilov le de 7000 élèves au
sein de la compagnie de tambours au
total ont reçu cet honneur d'ouvrir le
défilé solennelle des troupes qu'il
donne le rythme et le pas de marche aux
unités qui défilent
la compagnie d'honneur et sous les
ordres du colonel alexandre guerassimova
commandant l'école de musique militaire
devant les tribunes les porte drapeaux
de l'étendard de la victoire du drapeau
national de la fédération de russie et
de l'étendard des forces armées russes
ils sont sous les ordres du commandant
alex et rocklyn co ce groupe est
accompagné de la garde d'honneur des
trois armées forces terrestres
aérospatiale et navale
seuls les meilleurs du sang 54e régiment
de commandement près oprah gène ski qui
ont le droit de défiler au sein de la
garde d'honneur
ils sont commandés par le colonel
sergueï bessonova le volet historique du
défilé est ouvert par les militaires qui
porte les étendards des dix groupes
d'armées des différents fronts de
l'étape finale de la grande guerre
patriotique
sur la place rouge les 45 étendard de
combat des groupes d'armées et des
grands une idée c'est dans le plus lu
l'illustré au combat les reliques des
combats sont entre de bonnes mains
celles des héritiers des victoires des
soldats de la grande guerre patriotique
lé détachement d'honneur des unités de
l'époque de la grande guerre patriotique
des fils solennellement les premiers
sont les fantassins armée de célèbre
fusée mohcine c'est précisément
l'infanterie qui mêlait aux combats
incessants du premier jusqu'au dernier
jour dans le feu forza les victoires sur
les pavés de la place rouge les pilotes
antonio de l'époque de la guerre ce sont
eux qui dans des combats aériens
nettoyeur le ciel des vautours en asie
sur la place rouge les marins qui furent
durant la guerre un exemple de courage
et de vaillance
les marins sont suivis des sapeurs de la
grande guerre patriotique leur action et
leur dévouement sauvé des vies de soldat
rétablir la vie dans les villes en les
nettoyant des mines et des munitions sur
la place rouge
les unités de reconnaissance l'audace
l'ingéniosité et la foi en la victoire
voilà les efforts conjugués des unités
de reconnaissance derrière les lignes de
l'ennemi les soldats gardes frontières
se sont couverts d'une gloire
impérissable sur 485 poste frontière ils
furent les premiers à endurer l'écho de
l'ennemi menant un combat inégal
jusqu'à la dernière balle devant les
tribunes de la place rouge défile une
compagne est insurgé à l'été 1941 le
d'un million de citoyens soviétiques
intégrer les rangs des divisions de
volontaires a pour défendre leur patrie
et leur maison natale sur la place rouge
des films maintenant une unité de
cosaques sous les ordres du général
kozak nicolaï dowload a hâte à man de la
société des cosaques de russie pendant
la guerre bhl de 250 kozak furent
honorés du titre de héros de l'union
soviétique
le volet historique défilé sur la place
rouge s'achève ce par le passage
d'officier dans la tenue qui était celle
des vainqueurs en 1945
ils sont placés sous le commandement du
général andré topor aux vins nous avons
aujourd'hui l'honneur d'accueillir à ce
défilé de la victoire des militaires des
forces armées des pays de la coi et
c'est que d'autres pays amis sur la
place rouge défile un détachement de la
brigade de soldats de la paix de la
république d'azerbaïdjan sous les ordres
du commandant samica mammadov le de
600000 azerbaïdjanais passèrent à part
le creuset de la guerre 128 en main sur
heroes de l'union soviétique
le défilé se poursuit avec une unité des
forces armées de la république d'arménie
sous l'étendard historique de la 89e
division de fusiliers de taman l'unité
est placée sous le commandement du
colonel à chaude
hakobian ce les étendards de guerre un
des unités régulières et de partisans
des fils une unité de la garde d'honneur
des forces armées de la république de
biélorussie
elle est placée sous les ordres du
lieutenant ben ladislav chez p levitch
[Musique]
sur la place rouge
un détachement des trois armées
indiennes 1 sous les ordres du
commandant adjoint du régiment sic
d'infanterie légère en 1944 deux
militaires indiens furent décorés de
l'ordre de l'étoile rouge pour leur
courage
le kazakhstan maintenant est représenté
par une unité de la 36e prix cas de
dassault et les porter c'est le meilleur
complément des forces armées du
kazakhstan elle est placée sous les
ordres du colonel aland or ghazi et
recommandant de commandant la brigade
durant la guerre sur le territoire du
kazakhstan furent fort mais plus de 70
unités militaires
la place rouge un détachement des forces
armées de la république du kirghizstan
sous l'étendard de la huitième division
de fusiliers motorisée de la garde
générale pensez love
cette unité est placée sous le
commandement du colonel pkz domaine
bayer 20 devant les tribunes défile une
unité de la garde d'honneur de l'armée
populaire de libération chinoise sous
les ordres du général pas osé mines et
du colonel and juillet sur la place
rouge défile une compagnie de la garde
d'honneur de l'armée nationale de la
république de moldova moldavie elle est
placée sous les ordres du capitaine
vital et josanne devant la tribune et
défilent un détachement des forces
armées de mongolie sous les ordres du
colonel badel green catch r&d n'est
comme en danse de ce bataillon spécial
dès le premier jour de la guerre la
mongole et fut un allié fiable de
l'union soviétique sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel dragan jakovljevic
commandant du bataillon de la garde
une unité de militaires de la garde des
troupes de serbie défilent sur la place
rouge
le peuple serbe fut le premier en europe
à se lever contre l'agression nazie et
il gardera à jamais la mémoire des
combattants qui sont tombées sur la
place rouge des filets de jeunes
diplômés de l'institut militaire du
ministère de la défense du tadjikistan
ils sont placés sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel chris dodd a payé
mohammad
sur la place rouge des militaires des
forces armées du turkménistan sur les
voitures pobeda sont représentés le
drapeau national est l'étendard de
combat du 700 48e régiment des fusiliers
dans lequel combattait peur des mots km
en arrière grand père du président
tadjik devant les tribunes et passe
maintenant une unité d'honneur des
forces armées de la république
d'ouzbékistan télécommandé par le
colonel chakir cas et robert premier
adjoint au commandant des forces du
district militaire de tachkent
c'est maintenant au tour des jeunes
participants de défilé sur la place
rouge devant les tribunes défilent
solennellement une compagnie de
l'institut militaire
souvorov de moscou en juin 1945 210
anciens élèves de l'institut
participèrent pour la première fois au
défilé de la victoire
ils sont commandés par le connaît igor
lié kim of sur la place rouge les élèves
de l'institut militaire souvorov de la
ville de divers en 1943 l'institut
accueilli les premiers garçons des
années de guerre 18 d'entre eux furent
fils de régiments et gagnèrent des
décorations au combat le détachement est
sous les ordres du commandant de l'école
le colonel vladimir la rof sur les pavés
de la place rouge défile un détachement
d'honneur des jeunes élèves de l'école
nassim of de saint pétersbourg sous les
ordres du capitaine de vaisseau andré si
nevic plus de quinze mille officiers de
marine ont fait leurs premiers pas dans
la science navale dans les murs de cette
école sur la place rouge vous voyez
défiler de jeunes marins du corps de
cadets de marine de cronstadt en tête du
détachement le capitaine de vaisseau
nikolay doychinov besco commandant de
corps le corps des cadets depuis 25 ans
cet établissement forme la fumure la
future génération de commandant de la
flotte les meilleurs représentants du
mouvement paramilitaire et patriotique
yuna mialhe ce qui signifie jeune armées
participent au défilé de la victoire
ils sont au total dans tout le pays sept
cent cinquante mille leur détachement et
placés sous les ordres de romane
romanenko chef d'état-major du mouvement
pilote cosmonaute et héros de la
fédération de russie
sur la place rouge régiment des trucs
thérèse des forces armées de russie leur
marche est ouverte par des auditeurs de
l'académie interarmes des forces armées
de la fédération de russie
le détachement d'honneur est sous les
ordres du général alexandre romanes
chaude
la plupart des maréchaux de la victoire
et des commandants de l'armée rouge
firent leurs études dans les murs de
cette académie devant les tribunes
défile un détachement de l'université
militaire du ministère de la défense de
la fédération de russie sous les ordres
du général igor mishkin commandons
l'université celle ci est la seule école
militaire supérieur à orientation
humanitaire elle est le centre de
formation de spécialistes en matière
politique et militaire
sur la place rouge des élèves de
l'académie militaire d'artillerie
michailof le détachement d'honneur est
placée sous les ordres du colonel andré
titoff
c'est dans cette académie que sont
forgées depuis 200 ans des générations
d'officiers d'artillerie et de
spécialistes aux missiles 98 héros de
l'union soviétique de la fédération de
russie en sont issus aujourd'hui
l'académie forme des cadres supérieurs
pour tous les matériels d'artillerie et
de missiles en dotation dans l'armée
russe
[Musique]
sur la place rouge les élèves de
l'académie militaire de défense
antiaérienne maréchal wasilewski
le détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du général et gleb élus aux mines
comment dans l'académie durant les
années de guerre les hommes de la
défense contre avions à bâtir plus de
vingt mille appareils ennemis 57 d'entre
eux son héros de l'union soviétique
aujourd'hui l'académie forme des cadres
supérieurs pour les systèmes et complexe
de missiles sol air
[Musique]
sur la place rouge marche solennellement
l'académie militaire de matériel général
du golf qui fête ses 120 ans de
formation de cadres de l'intendance le
détachement d'honneur et placés sous les
ordres du général vladimir konovalov
défilent sous vos yeux des effectifs
féminins des établissements
d'enseignement militaire supérieur de
russie futurs officiers des forces
aérospatiale de l'intendance des
interprètes militaires des juristes et
des responsables financiers
elles sont placés sous les ordres des
commandants maria da silva et yekaterina
à la roma
ces jeunes filles ont pour exemple les
participants de la grande guerre
patriotique 93 femmes pendant la guerre
furent héros de l'union soviétique
quatre d'entre elles
chevalier à part entière de l'ordre de
la gloire devant les tribunes des filins
régiment des forces à éros dacia halle
de russie il comprend des officiers des
élèves de l'académie aérospatiale
joukovski et gagarine
le détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du général guennadi ziouganov
comment dans l'académie aujourd'hui
l'académie forme des officiers dans 70
spécialités de base en matière
didactique et matériels de matériels
aériens de pointe évolutif de drones de
systèmes de gestion des vols basés à
terre et de conduite de radars
en cent ans d'histoire l'académie a
formé des dizaines de milliers
d'officiers qui ont apporté une
contribution considérable à la conquête
de l'espace
plus de 1500 diplômé de l'académie en
temps de paix et pendant la guerre ont à
juste titre mérité le titre élevé de
héros de l'union soviétique et de la
fédération de russie
plus de 60 d'entre eux se sont vus
décerner ce titre deux fois et même
trois fois pour le maréchal d'aviation
ivanko des doubles diplômes et également
de cette académie
aujourd'hui le détachement de l'académie
comprend des représentants de dynasty
d'officiers qui trouvent leur source
dans les premiers concurrents du ciel et
de mettre de l'aviation
sur la place rouge un détachement
d'honneur de l'académie spatiales
militaires mojaïsk il est placé sous les
ordres du général maxime pine cove
directeur de l'académie durant la guerre
l'académie a formé des pilotes notamment
des pilotes d'essai y compris le célèbre
race alexandre patrick kane trois fois
héros de l'union soviétique
aujourd'hui l'académie est le principal
établissement de formation et de
recherche pour les spécialistes en fusée
spatiale
[Musique]
sur la place rouge un régiment des
forces navales de la fédération de
russie
il est commandé par le contre-amiral
viacheslav site nique
le détachement d'honneur comprend des
élèves de l'institut supérieur navale
ushakov situé dans la ville de
kaliningrad
parmi les dix-huit mille anciens élèves
on compte 80 amiraux généraux et
commandants de flotte de flottille de
navires et de sous-marins
[Musique]
sur la place rouge des marins au long
cours des élèves de l'institut supérieur
naval able amiral makarov de l'océan
pacifique
défilent sous les ordres du capitaine de
vaisseau handrich mac os durant ses 80
années d'histoire l'institut a formé
plus de vingt mille officiers parmi eux
18 héros de l'union soviétique de la
russie et du travail socialiste
devant les tribunes défilent
d'infanterie de marine sa devise
principale est là où nous sommes là et
la victoire
la fonderie de marine est représentée
dans ce défilé par la 33 136e brigade de
la garde de bialystok de la flotte de la
baltique de la baltique
sous les ordres du colonel andré la zone
chine
les troupes de missiles stratégiques
sont représentés par des officiers des
élèves de l'académie militaire pierre le
grand
le détachement d'honneur est commandée
par le général leonid microapp
commandant l'académie les élèves de
l'académie apporte une contribution
énorme dans la création et le
développement des forces nucléaires
stratégiques de la russie
cet établissement militaire qui figurent
parmi les plus anciens du pays fêtera
cette année ses 200 ans
[Musique]
le détachement d'honneur de la filiale
dans la ville de ces reports of de
l'académie est sous les ordres du
commandant andré malraux
aujourd'hui cet institut forme des
officiers devront commander les nouveaux
types de complexes d'armes permettant
d'assurer la sécurité la souveraineté de
la fédération de russie
[Musique]
sur la place rouge les militaires des
troupes aéroportées
la marche est ouverte par les élèves de
l'institut supérieur des troupes
aéroportées de riazan générales malg
alors sous les ordres de son commandant
le général alex et ragots zine à
différentes périodes plus de cinquante
mille anciens élèves ont formé par leur
héroïsme et leur courage la gloire des
troupes aéroportées 135 d'entre eux son
héros de l'union soviétique et de la
fédération de russie
vous voyez défiler le 300 31e régiment
de parachutistes de la garde de la ville
de kostroma de la 98ème division
aéroportée le détachement est sous les
ordres du colonel
oleg orlov le régime en garde la mémoire
sacrée des héros des anciens combattants
de la guerre ayant participé à la
libération de l'engrais de la
tchécoslovaquie et de l'autriche où
[Musique]
sur la place rouge des parachutistes du
sens 4e régiment d'assaut héliportée de
la garde
le détachement d'honneur est placée sous
les ordres du colonel alexandre ship of
commandant le régiment
cette année le régime en fête les 20 ans
de l'exploit accompli dans un combat
inégal par des hommes de la sixième
compagnie pour leur héroïsme et leur
courage 22 parachutistes de la sixième
compagnie ont été déclaré héros de la
fédération de russie
la marche se poursuit avec l'institut de
protection des frontières du fsb le
détachement est sous les ordres du
général valérie cazes rohff commandant
l'institut les gardes frontières assure
la mission de protection de la frontière
nationale et l'institut est déjà formé
plus de cinquante mille officiers pour
les services de sécurité sur la place
rouge défile un détachement d'honneur
des troupes du génie sous les ordres du
colonel alexandre malkoff il comprend
des soldats les soldats les plus
valeureux de la 1ère brigade du génie
brest berlin et de la 45e brigade du
génie de la gare de berlin
sur la place rouge vous voyez défiler un
détachement de troupes de protection
nucléaire bactériologique et chimique
à savoir des auditeurs de l'académie
maréchal timoshenko le détachement est
commandée par le général igor emelyanov
les diplômés de cette académie
remplissent leur devoir
consciencieusement effectué des
opérations humanitaires
un détachement des transmissions des
fils représentés par des élèves de
l'académie militaire maréchal
bouillonner il est sous les ordres du
général sergueï kostine f représentant
commandant l'académie en 100 ans
d'histoire 46000 commandant et
ingénieurs des transmissions y ont été
formés
devant les tribunes défile un bataillon
des troupes ferroviaire le détachement
d'honneur comprend les meilleurs
militaire de différentes brigades
ferroviaire et est commandée par le
colonel igor orlov commandant la 38e
brigade pour leur contribution précieuse
à la victoire 29 militaires des troupes
ferroviaire se virent remettre le titre
de héros du travail socialistes et héros
de l'union soviétique
sur la place principale d'une pays
défilent un détachement d'honneur de
l'académie de sécurité civile du
ministère des situations d'urgence ce
détachement et placés sous les ordres du
général victor pantchenkov comment dans
l'académie le ministère des situations
d'urgence fait cette année son 30e
anniversaire
[Musique]
vous voyez passer un détachement de la
division autonome des jeunes ce qui des
troupes de la garde nationale de la
fédération de russie
le détachement est placée sous le
commandement du général mitri chez les
pats nov
comment dans la division il ya 75 ans
les militaires de la division avait jeté
devant le mausolée
les étendards et les drapeaux d unité
nazie vaincu
sur la place principale de pays défilent
un détachement de la 2e division de
fusiliers motorisés kalinin de taman il
est sous les ordres du général
iguiniz nikitine durant la guerre 34
fusillé furent déclarés héros de l'union
soviétique
5 chevalier de l'ordre de la gloire tout
place sur la place rouge défile un
détachement de la quatrième division de
chars de la garde
antropov de contenir il est commandé par
le colonel vladimir vaz qui commet dans
la division pendant la guerre les
équipages de chars de la division
cantemir participèrent aux combats les
plus décisifs sur le fond dans les
opérations de libération des pays
d'europe
le défilé à pied s'achève avec les
élèves de l'institut de commandement
interarmes de moscou
le détachement est sous les ordres du
général romane biniou koz depuis que le
défilé sur la place rouge existe
les élèves du kremlin non ne manquait
qu'un seul en novembre 1941 le régiment
des élèves officiers se couvrit d'une
loi impérissable c'est enlever tel un
mur face à l'ennemi pour l'empêcher de
parvenir jusqu'à la capitale
800 aux élèves officiers tombèrent dans
les combats pour la défense de moscou
le courage l'héroïsme et l'abnégation
ont toujours été la caractéristique des
élèves du kremlin les 109 anciens de
l'institut devenu héros de l'union
soviétique de la russie et du travail
socialiste pour leurs exploits et leurs
faits d'armes en sont la confirmation
les musiciens quittent la place rouge
pour laisser la voie libre au défilé
mécanisée enfermement à la tradition
l'accompagnement musical est assurée par
l'orchestré militaire de la garnison de
moscou la musique militaire est exécutée
sous la baguette du général c'est ma
fille maya keane chef de leur quête
principale militaire pendant le défilé
lors qu'est ce militaire interprète plus
de 50 marches et oeuvres musicales
[Musique]
c'est le début du défilé des troupes
mécanisées ce défilé a réuni du matériel
de l'époque de la seconde guerre
mondiale et de l'armement moderne en
dotation dans les unités des forces
armées russes le droit d'ouvrir le volet
historique du défilé mécanisée confiée
aux militaires de la première armée de
chars sous le commandement du général
sergueï keith l
ils sont à bord de célèbres char t34
durant la guerre cette armée de chars a
mené des combats de koursk à berlin et a
détruit bhl de 7000 chars canons
automoteurs et véhicules blindés ennemis
après l'été 34 suivre les chasseurs de
chars automoteurs saussan sous les
ordres du lieutenant et accor en asie
durant la guerre leur mission de combat
était de détruire des chars ennemis
est ce que d'assurer un appui feu aux
troupes amies
[Musique]
et voici le matériel actuel des forces
armées russes
les premiers à passer devant les
tribunes sont les véhicules à roues de
la 16ème brigade spéciale ce sont les
véhicules blindés multi rôles tigray et
typhoon qui sont équipés de différents
modules de combat télécommande et la
colonne est commandé par le
lieutenant-colonel anatolie vastine fait
son apparition sur la place rouge une
colonne de véhicules de combat
d'infanterie bmp de m
armé du nouveau système de combat bear
head up et de véhicules de combat
d'infanterie b3 qui sont équipés d'un
système de protection dynamique qui
augmente considérablement les
possibilités de survie du personnel à
son bord 1
cette colonne est sous les ordres du
chef de bataillon igor matveïev
viennent ensuite les nouveaux véhicules
blindés de lutte antiaérienne dérive
attiyah pvo
ainsi que les véhicules de combat
d'infanterie sur châssis de corgan est
25è d'armata ils sont armés de modules
de combat epoca équine chalain la
colonne est sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel sa caisse à la côte
d'innovant
sur la place rouge des films maintenant
une colonne de véhicules de combat de
soutien de chars mpt terminator leurs
missions principales
c'est le puits furent aux chars de
combat l'unité et sur les autres du
capitaine à l'exo tikhonov
sur la place rouge des films maintenant
un groupe de chars de combat t 72 23
appartenant au 1er régiment de chars de
chartres comment les chars sont placés
sous le commandement du capitaine rinat
rafik aux vins
les pavés de la place rouge accueille
les chartes et 80 bbm propulsé par
turbine à gaz et appartenant à la 200e
brigade mécanisée de pachuca seul centre
du cap et d'alexandre un corner chine
comme à l'époque de la guerre et les
militaires de cette brigade protège les
régions arctique de la russie
vient ensuite une colonne de la 27e
brigade de sébastopol elle présente le
matériel blindé le plus moderne en
dotation dans l'armée russe et les chars
tu es 14 armata étaient 80 m prévoit la
colonne est amené par le chef de
bataillon constante est au sol ses vins
les troupes de missiles et l'artillerie
des forces armées russes se sont
représentés par une colonne de la 236e
brigade d'artillerie qui est équipé d'un
huissier automoteurs de 152 mm masta ace
et quality hsv sur les autres du chef de
bataillon mikhail malines la cadence de
tir et les systèmes de conduite de tir
de haute précision permettent aux
artilleurs de détruire des cibles à
distance maximale
maintenant vous voyez un groupe de
lance-roquettes multiples tornado s
appartenant à la 439e brigade
d'artillerie de père écope
ils sont sous les ordres du commandant
dimitri abakumova
sur les pavés de la place rouge défilé
des systèmes de missiles balistiques de
haute précision iskander m appartenant à
la 112e brigade domicile de novorossiisk
le drapeau de cette brigade est décoré
de cet ordre militaire reçu pour la
libération de neuf ans précise que le
franchissement du dniepr et de l'oder et
la prise de berlin
le détachement est placée sous les
ordres du commandant il y à l'aube
atteint 20
font leur apparition sur la place rouge
des détachements des troupes terrestres
de lutte antiaérienne la colonne est
constitué de systèmes d'armes solaire
tort m 2 appartenant au régiment de
tarnopol et bouc m3 de la 35e brigade de
missiles sol air elle est placée sous
les ordres du lieutenant colonel
alexandre molia vinh ces systèmes
antiaériens permettent de détruire
toutes cibles aériennes
[Musique]
font leur apparition sur la place
roussel et la rampe de lancement du
système d'armes sol air s 300 v 4 de la
77e brigade missiles sol air sous les
ordres du lieutenant colonel denis
tricorder m
ces systèmes d'armes protège les troupes
au sol contre toute menace à l
aérodynamique et balistiques aux
distances et aux altitude maximale
et voici le matériel des troupes
aéroportées appartenant à la 116e
division parachutiste de tous là ce sont
les véhicules blindés de combat des
photos rien reporter bmd 4ème et bud rm
dm marrakech car ils sont placés sous
les ordres du lieutenant colonel métrite
aux mines
la place rouge accueille maintenant les
systèmes de lance-flammes leur
moderniser tos un as de la 1ère brigade
mobile des troupes de protection nbc
l'unité est placée sous les ordres du
capitaine ève guesnier speed sin
[Musique]
vous voyez maintenant la nouvelle
version de lance flammes alors tous deux
sur châssis de camion orale qui possède
une porte de feu très grande
ainsi que les véhicules de minage à
distance et isdn qui sont capables de
poser des mines sur le champ de bataille
avec une grande précision
ce détachement est commandée par le
commandant énorme in case au vin
la place rouge à que les systèmes
anti-aériens des forces air spatiale
vous voyez d'abord les différentes
versions de véhicules entiers ria
missiles canon feu les ordres du
lieutenant colonel alexandre rochatte
ordre
c'est le système d'armes dernier panty
rsm et sa version précédente panshir s
ils sont suivis de la version acte hic
panshir s à
le 6 ans 6e régiment de missiles sol air
représente les systèmes d'armes s es 350
viti gaz et s 4 400 triumph uns sur les
autres et du commandant denis ce droit
est chauvin les performances de ses
systèmes dépasse les capacités des
systèmes antiaériens des autres pays
maintenant la place aux as que les
systèmes de missiles de défense côtière
balle qui équipe la 536e brigade
d'artillerie côtière de la flotte du
nord composé de véhicules de
commandement de véhicules lance missiles
et de véhicules de transport et de
chargement de missiles ce système
d'armes est capable de détruire tout
navire ennemi et garantit ainsi la
protection de la zone côtière de la
russie
les véhicules sont placés sous les
ordres du lieutenant colonel de maîtrise
corbel nico 20
viennent ensuite les véhicules blindés
tigre et iphone à de la police militaire
sous les ordres du commandant pavel
maxime auvin ces véhicules ont fait
leurs preuves en république arabe
syrienne lors de l'accompagnement par la
police militaire des convoi qui
transportait de l'aide humanitaire et
lors de patrouilles conjointes sur les
routes et les checkpoints
fait son entrée sur la place rouge la
colonne mécanisée de la garde nationale
russe sous les ordres du capitaine alex
est cher mais vain les cartes nationales
et dotés de véhicules blindés tigray et
patrouille orale de fabrication russe
ils permettent de remplir leurs missions
dans les conditions les plus difficiles
et en tout terrain sur la place rouge
défilent les missiles intercontinentaux
des forces stratégiques appartenant à la
54e division domicile sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel y avait gagné
gontcharova le missile balistique
stratégique milhars est capable de se
déplacer à travers les grands espaces
sans être détectés et de pénétrer
d'autres défense antimissile m le
missile stratégique yaars c'est le
fleuron du groupement mobile des forces
nucléaires russes
le défilé mécanisée s'achève avec la
présentation des véhicules de combat
d'infanterie ce robot merengues en
portant les drapeaux des différentes
désormais des forces armées de la
fédération de russie
ces véhicules sont capables d'embarquer
différents modules de combat et assure
une protection pour le personnel à bord
nous allons suivre maintenant le volet
arrière du défilé ce matin 75 appareils
hélicoptères et avions des forces
aérospatiale russe ont décollé de 8
aérodromes et ont formé des patrouilles
dans une zone située aux environs de
moscou pour passer ensuite au dessus de
la place rouge
les appareils volts à l'altitude de 150
à 400 mètres à une vitesse de 200 à 500
km heure le défilé est ouvert par
l'hélicoptère de transport ayant la plus
grande charge utile au monde
le mil mi 26 accompagné de quatre
hélicoptères multi rôles 1800 et chats
le groupe est conduit par le lieutenant
colonel sergueï poliakov
vous voyez maintenant une formation de
cinq hélicoptères de transport et de
combat mi 35 m
sous les ordres du lieutenant colonel
guennadi goudkov viennent ensuite cinq
hélicoptères de combat kamov ka 52
alligator ce sont des hélicoptères
d'appui feu des troupes au sol la
formation conduite par le colonel
vassili klitschko voici la patrouille
d'accrocs brice d'acrobaties aériennes
berkut aigle royal sur cinq hélicoptères
d'attaqué mil mi 28n baptisé chasseurs
donné la patrouille est placée sous les
ordres du colonel
andrei popov
[Musique]
vous voyez un avion de détection de
commandement est reportée à 50 ou
capable de suivre en même temps plus de
50 cibles aériennes
l'avion est piloté par le
lieutenant-colonel viatcheslav lifting
qu'on vient ensuite une formation de
trois avions de transport militaire
longs courriers il 76 mde moderniser
capable d'acheminer un fred de plus de
40 tonnes dans des régions dans les
régions les plus éloignées
la formation conduite par le commandant
sergei melnikov vous voyez passer trois
bombardiers stratégiques lourd à
turbopropulseurs tupou relève tu 95 m s
c'est une des composante aérienne des
forces de dissuasion nucléaire la
formation est placée sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel sergueï line
l'aviation stratégique et représente
également par une patrouille composée
d'un bombardent et tuent paul f tus 160
à géométrie variable et de quatre
bombardiers supersoniques à long rayon
d'action du pôle f 22 m3 la patrouille
est conduite par le commandant alex &
wollensky
les pilotes des forces aérospatiale font
la démonstration d'une opération
extrêmement délicate qui demande une
grande précision
c'est le ravitaillement en vol d'un
bombardier stratégique tupolev tu 160
l'avion ravitailleur est un îlot chine
1078 dans le ciel de moscou une
patrouille de quatre chasseurs de
supériorité aérienne mig 29smt et
modernisé sous les ordres du lieutenant
colonel your guide audio
la formation suivante est composé de
quatre bombardiers tactiques de première
ligne su wei sur 24 m
conduits par le lieutenant colonel
germann à naroff
vient ensuite une patrouille de
chasseurs intercepteurs sur personne etc
à long rayon d'action mig-31 cas c'est
une version modernisée armés de missiles
king charles composantes redoutable de
dissuasion la patrouille est placée sous
les ordres du commandant riguet niche à
l'aig
vous voyez passer une formation de
quatre avions de combat polyvalents de
cinquième génération su qu ils 57
conduite par le lieutenant colonel
vladimir voltchkov voltchkov
dans le ciel de moscou une patrouille
tactiques de combats comprenant dix
appareils quatre bombardiers tactiques
sugoi 34 4 chasseurs polyvalents sucre
30 s m et quatre chasseurs polyvalents
sukhoï su 35 s la patrouille est sous
les ordres du colonel iouri grichenko et
voici deux patrouilles aériennes parmi
les meilleurs au monde
neuf appareils des risques évités asie
l'eprus et des stryges et martinet sur
500 kw / france
sm et 4029 ils forment la figure
baptisée diamant de combines qu'à la
formation est conduite par le colonel
andré alekseev par tradition le défilé
aérien s'achève par le passage de six
avions d'attaqué au sol sucrage 25 bm
sur le commandement du colonel alexandre
kotov
il laisse dans le ciel un panache avec
les trois couleurs du drapeau russe
le défilé s'achève par le chant jour de
la victoire
interprété par la musique militaire
[Musique]
ainsi se termine le défilé militaire des
célébrations du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire qui a mis fin à la grande
guerre patriotique la musique militaire
quitte la place rouge
[Musique]
le défilé de la victoire est terminée
vive le 75e anniversaire de la grande
victoire
gloire aux anciens combattants de la
grande guerre patriotique
bonne fête de la victoire à tous les
russes hourra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et